[Music]
you may have heard this now that Disney
owns the Star Wars franchise cuz Disney
bought Star Wars well now that they have
Disney's gonna cut some of the more
obscure characters and television
spin-offs that have been added over the
years now a lot of people think that the
Star Wars franchise and spring spread
too thin too long it's not that deluded
time to cut it back that's what Disney
is doing now I mentioned this last week
Disney has already eliminated some less
popular Star Wars characters for example
characters like r2d2 sister who lives in
Las Vegas are 2d cups
yeah the diet spokesman Jenny Craig
Jabba the Hutt has been cut they also
discontinued a series of Star Wars
romantic novels they got rid of though
come on you guys knew right exactly you
guys knew they pulled Yoda they pulled
some products off the shelf like Admiral
Akbar brand flytraps
it's a drug
they can't sold several spin-off TV
shows including How I Met Your Greedo
Keeping Up with the calrissian that's
been canceled the unpopular game show
hosted by Jabba's right-hand man wheel
of Fortuna and the movie spin-off Tyler
Perry c-3po oh good good
none of them were good